hey what's up guys my name is channel
welcome back to another hazel devlog so
last week
i'll put up a video right there yes week
i'm actually so excited i've managed to
make
two devlogs in two weeks but anyway last
time we talked about how
i was having a bunch of falcon issues
basically so
the driver would crash falcon wouldn't
really give me much information
i tried debugging out i couldn't really
get anywhere validation layers were
giving me nothing and all of that
and uh and today i'm here to tell you
that everything's working
so the first thing that i want to do is
thank all of you
and all of your suggestions i to be
honest when i
when i explained the problem in the
devlog i didn't really expect
as much helpful information as i got
i mean not only were there tons of
comments suggesting that i do this or
that i also got emails and
you know various other messages on other
platforms being like hey have you heard
of this have you tried that
and by following your advice i solved my
problem
and today i'm going to show you how that
happened and the key is a little
something called
nvidia aftermath so i
hadn't actually heard of this before
and again this is thanks to you guys
that i mean
you know this is why it's so great to
share your development with the world
right you get all these helpful
um resources and uh feedback from the
community but basically what nvidia
aftermath
is nvidia and site aftermath i guess
they're calling it it's a simple library
that you integrate into directx 12 or
vulkan's game crash reporter
um to generate gpu mini dumps when
basically a crash occurs right so um
what you can do is you basically
download this library uh
anyone can do this right you can you
have to sign up for like an nvidia
develo
developer account but that's like
totally free and it's pretty
straightforward
um this is completely free the license
is pr is pretty permissive as well
so in other words you can actually ship
this with your game or with your app if
you want to so that you can get kind of
feedback um from like client crashes in
like a distribution environment as well
not just for debugging which is great
but basically whenever you get like a
crash in your gpu
and um aftermath will actually dump all
of the details of that crash to a file
and then you can open it in
with nvidia and site which is like a
graphics debugging tool
and actually see what's up so that's
exactly what i did okay so just a little
side note as i'm editing this i didn't
mention this in the video but
aftermath and video aftermath only works
on nvidia gpus
just in case that's a surprise um so a
few days ago
basically like two days after i put up
that video and i read all of your
suggestions
i um i i had two issues actually with
vulcan that i knew would cause like a
device lost error
and thus would crash the driver um and
what happens is i i set up the uh
nvidia gpu okay actually no i need to
show you guys what i actually did
so there's this um github repository
and n-site aftermath samples um
which basically has like a directx 12
and a vulcan example and it's pretty
cool
um there's all these files but there's
the main file i think which actually has
the uh well it's this one vk hello and
site aftermath this actually has the
usage of this little library they've
written
that uses the aftermath library which is
like the aftermath gpu crash tracker
um and uh so in other words this
actually enables aftermath and
um you know hooks up their little gpu
crash tracker which is over here and
then you
like hook it up before you create like
the vulcan device basically
um so i looked at this example and this
example actually features like a vulcan
device loss crash you can actually see
it happening
over here what is it device lost error
device loss so if error device lost
happens in their example
they just sleep for three seconds to
make sure that the asynchronous
um uh you know file writing has time to
actually finish before like you exit in
this case
but whatever the point is that they've
got a really nice sample um and that's
one of the things that i love about
nvidia's
uh libraries is that they generally have
pretty good samples
um so this is what i based it off of and
i basically grabbed these files i
chucked them into hazel
i hooked up the gpu crash tracker in
much the same way and then what happened
is when i got a device lost
it dumped out two files to disk so i'm
going to be using this one as an example
i've got a bunch in this repository
he also dumped out a shader file and so
what these are is one of them is just a
gpu dump file which if you open up um
and site so we'll open up nsite here
which you can also
download for free um we can just
drag this in and as long as you've got
your
shader paths hooked up correctly so what
this shader
kind of hash file is is actually like a
debug file for the shader itself
so aftermath can do a whole bunch this
isn't really a video about aftermath
this is more like a postmortem kind of
crash
you know situation i guess it's a devlog
right if you guys want me to actually
put together a proper
insight um aftermath like tutorial or
whatever let me know
but uh this is more just kind of my
experience in a bit of more of a high
level view but basically this shader
um this shader file contains like
my understanding is it's got like the
debug kind of symbols um of the actual
shader itself i'm not sure if
uh you might actually i don't think it
has the source code i think you have to
hook that up as well and i'll show you
how in a minute
but basically this has um information
about where exactly in the like what the
shader was doing all of the indications
of like the fragment shader for example
what what was happening at the time of
the crash which is really cool
and i'll actually show you that here so
if you go
tools options it's a bit weird this is
global but under search paths
right you can actually set this up
because you can see at the moment
i think i've got it in a few different
situations here yeah so say for example
shader object file not found right
um and the reason that that happened is
because i haven't hooked up my
search paths correctly so for example
for the driver
shader output paths instead of this
which is like a different branch i guess
of hazel
we can hook in let's change this to just
be
editor workflow which is the dump we
opened that's a branch
and if i select that and hit okay
then you can see now it's actually
saying assets shaders skybox.json if i
double click on it i actually get source
code
and it actually tells me the exact line
that it was that was being executed when
this like
happened um which is really cool now
um i will say though that if you're
looking at this being like how
is the open bracket crashing this um you
have to remember that the source code
like in hazel for example and the source
code in your engine potentially as well
is might not align correctly so this is
clearly a fragment shader
right and we know that it's line 18 that
caused the issue
but if you look at this this is actually
like a
hazel shader which has type vertex type
fragments so both shaders are in one
file there's comments before that so we
know that the text that is actually sent
to like you know spur v to compile
everything is this
for the vertex shader and this for the
fragment shader so really what's going
on is it's saying line 18
of this text so clearly it's not that um
and i can't
uh if i open up like a vs code or
something
and i paste this in um and there might
be like a space or something so like i
always give or take a line
but basically this is kind of what we're
left with if we just paste that text in
as it is and you can see that line 18 is
that it's probably not that it's
probably this
right so we know that the line that
seems to have crashed is
this texture access which if you if we
actually read the crash i kind of went
forward into the shader
but if you look at what actually
happened in the dump info we can see
that it was a page fault right which is
like a memory access problem
and then in the crash info you can see
that there's some page fault going on
here's the address
here's the address of like this resource
that it's trying to access which is what
actually caused the issue
um the size we can see here is 512
megabytes with height
2048 2048 depth 6 mip levels 12. so we
have information about the texture
itself that it's trying to read
we know that obviously it's some kind of
resource access that was a problem and
if you look at the gpu state you can
even see
that it was in fact texture um and that
the texture access
faulted everything else seems good busy
or idle right that's fine
but something went wrong with like
texture operations right
and this is the actual texture so this
actually by itself
before you even hook up that shader
source code has so much interesting
information
that i mean i can immediately identify
that texture it's clearly
going to be a cube map right the depth
is six it's got six faces six
layers mip levels 12 well the mid levels
12 correspond with like the width and
height
so i know it's a 2048 by 2048 cube map
right there are only two of those um no
there's only one of those actually in in
the engine and that's like the
environment map
right so clearly accessing the
environment map is problematic and why
it looks like in the sky box shader when
when it actually tries to draw the um
you know the background i guess uh
it's failing because it can't read the
texture
so um that immediately showed me
um one of the problems that i had um
which was
and and this is like as i said i had two
issues with vulcan
just you know error device lost um one
was
somewhat weird and happening on random
devices and we'll get to that in a
minute but then there was this one which
was like 100
reproducible and basically uh what this
ended up being was
um instead of what i was doing is
i was deleting my old environment map so
if i played with like my little praythem
sky model or if i tried to load if i
tried to
try it it's great if i tried to load
like another cube map or something like
that um
i i was deleting the old one but i
wasn't submitting
the deletion of that memory and that
image view and all the other things
into the render command queue so i was
just doing it immediately
so as soon as the ref as soon as the
reference count hits zero
and we are kind of left with uh you know
a texture or a resource that has no
references that should be deleted
i was immediately calling those falcon
delete functions and i guess what
happened was this fragment chair was was
either in flight or about to be rendered
or whatever
um and i guess it had already passed
validation and it would have been like
everything's fine and now we're going to
render it oh wait
it's been deleted i can't access that
memory anymore or whatever
and it was just giving me like a device
lost with absolutely no validation or
anything like that
so uh what i did was i just submitted it
to the render command queue like it
should have been done and that means
that it happens
after like the render operation takes
place and everything's done
and that fixed it so that was the first
issue
the second issue um which was the most
serious one in my opinion because this
one was
somewhat new and it was reproducible
reproducible is always good not
reproducible is always bad
um so the second one uh happened on some
devices
and that should have been a hint now in
retrospect because now that i know why
it makes sense um so it probably uh
means that i need to pay more attention
and be a better detective
or something but basically um what would
happen is
on my computer very rarely when i loaded
a cube map
like an environment map the way that
happens in hazel i described that a
little bit in the last devlog but
basically we load like an echo
rectangular image we filter it and then
we generate like an irradiance map from
that as well
i mean we generate like all the lots oh
sorry all the mip levels and everything
um
and so basically we run like three
different compute shaders to make all
that happen
uh and i had been really like you know
i've been really safe with that like
um i knew that like potentially maybe
you know uh synchronization issues could
cause that usually
in my experience synchronization issues
so in other words if you don't finish
writing to a compute shader
if your compute if your computer is
writing to a texture
and you don't finish that operation
before you start rendering that texture
in a fragment shader
usually that doesn't really cause like a
crash or a device thing it just means
like your data is missing or like
you might see flickering you know stuff
like that um usually it's not like a
hard crash at least in my in my
experience but anyway so
just to be super safe i put fences
everywhere
okay so i think taking a look at is
probably going to make more sense but
basically what i did is when i when i
submitted
my actual like compute shader to the
compute like command q
in vulcan um i had made sure basically
that uh
after i do that there's this fence that
we wait for
after the submission so nothing else
happens the cpu literally just
waits here uh for however long that
compute trader takes and then it
continues so that means literally
nothing else could possibly happen
while we wait for this unless like some
other stuff has been previously
submitted to the queue
but it wouldn't because like in in c
plus land when we submit things we do
the cube map first obviously because
you've just decided you want to load it
there can't possibly be already a
submission to render the new one before
you've
anyway so basically uh what that also
means um conveniently is that we can
time this right easily we can just
create like a cpu timer
and just see how long this this takes
because once you submit something to a
queue if you wait for the fans to
complete if you wait for the
you know for everything to finish then
you also know how long it takes which is
nice
so i was also able to see i guess how
long this
execution took and i mean i looked at it
and it didn't seem like it was too bad
like it
you know for one of the shaders it was
like a few milliseconds for another one
it was like half a second and then like
the irradiance one took like two seconds
2.2 seconds something like that
and i was like okay sure whatever 2.2
seconds you know a little bit of time
but
you know we're filtering this cube map
we're trying to make it pretty this is
not like this is like a loading
operation it's not a per frame operation
obviously
so whatever um but then one thing that i
noticed
was happening is that again as i
mentioned on this computer which isn't
like it's a 1080 ti
it's not the the best card you can get
these days but it's a pretty strong card
um it was the fastest on this and
i couldn't get the crash that happened
very often on my laptop which is hooked
up to that
monitor in the background um that's got
an
rtx 2060 but it's a mobile chip uh
because the laptop
and um it was happening way more
frequently not every time but maybe like
when i hit f5 to run
hazelnut and i was loading a cube map
you know which i just
had to do on startup it would happen
like
one every five times one every 10 times
something like that
um but then for other people on the
hazel team like peter notably
he was getting this every single time
which was crazy
uh i was like what like this you can't
load any cube masks what's going on
and he has the weakest card he's got a
750 ti
uh which i think he says
it took like four seconds or five
seconds or i don't know it was way
slower
and i was like okay that's interesting
so but i didn't i didn't realize that at
the time
maybe i should have been like on lower
tier hardware it seems to be crashing
more often
um up to the point where it just crashes
every single time um
but i didn't notice that until nvidia
aftermath again to the rescue
i set it up on that laptop because again
on here it happened so
infrequently that it was like whatever
and i got some pretty
interesting results and so this
is the dump from the laptop which i
just copied so let's take a look at this
one
i'm not going to bother hooking up the
shader because the problem is actually
pretty visible here
so and here's the thing right like when
i first saw this it took me a little bit
of time here
when i first saw this i was like there
is
so little information here but it's kind
of almost like a less is more situation
not really but like
my point i wouldn't be opposed to more
information but the thing is
this amount of information was enough
for me to figure out what was going on
right in both both cases it it's like
deceptively
little amount of information it looks
like it's not much much information but
it's there's actually a lot of stuff
here and especially once you hook once
you hook up the shaders and everything
as well but basically um you can see and
you can see this is like from thursday
last week
um this is what happened so device state
is hung
right to contrast this with the other
one right the device state was
a page fault right okay whatever memory
access
bad you know we can maybe take a look at
this
but this state was literally hung and in
the compute
channel it seems right um that's all
that we really have here and then in the
crash info again if we were to hook up
the shadow we can see kind of
all the different invocations of the
compute shader um
which of course kind of running in
parallel and you can actually see like
what it's executing
i hooked that up on the laptop it wasn't
that useful it was just random points in
the compute shader basically
um and you can see that over here you
know we have all of these like pipelines
being busy whatever
and if you do hook this up as i
mentioned you you would see where you
were in the shader
but none of that is really that
interesting um we know which shader it
is
so again i didn't copy the shader object
file but if i open it on that computer i
can see
that it's the environment irradiance.jsl
shader
right so it literally says kind of like
what we had here with the shader
location
being an actual file right it also had
that there so i knew which shader
which compute shader was causing the
problem um which was coincidentally
the one that takes the longest so as i
mentioned like over two seconds on this
computer
like four or five seconds for peter or
whatever it was right
um and device date was hung so
what seems to be happening is that that
compute shader is taking so much time
that the driver is like
something's not right which i mean like
two three seconds or even five seconds
for a computer i would not have thought
that that would have been too much like
maybe 30 seconds a minute whatever i
expect people are doing some kind of
compute operations
on their gpus that are taking a long
time
um why is this you know
why is it suddenly like oh two seconds
two three seconds
you did not just say three seconds i'm
cutting i'm abort mission
crash the driver i don't know why right
but what i do know is that i lowered the
quality of the environment um
irradiance map compute shader so
basically
load the number of samples as i saw we
as i showed we were doing like 2048 by
2048 for the rest of the q maps load
that's like 10 24 because it's usually
good enough right
most of this stuff is just being used
for like reflections and um you know
2048 is pretty overkill i just like to
you know turn stuff
up to like 11 and just see what's up
2048 is
is admittedly quite a lot you saw it was
taking 512 megabytes of vram i mean it's
uncompressed data and everything
but 512 megabytes of vram for a single
queue map
is quite a bit right so whatever you
know let's turn that down
we turned peters down significantly down
to like um i think we were doing a
quarter
of the irradiance samples which is just
basically how much
how how much is sample so therefore you
lower the samples obviously the computer
is going to be way faster
and we lowered it to like 1024 for the
size
and he never got a crash again so
long story short um if you
take too long in your computer shader
you will lose the device
um i did not know this uh i i
didn't really generally find that out
from my reset i even asked like
friends of mine from ea you know have
you seen this before
um no so i don't know
um i don't know how common this is i'm
not sure if it's something i think i
think some
someone on my discord mentions something
about like you can change this in the
registry or something so that it
it will maybe wait 10 seconds or
whatever before being like okay
i'm aborting the whole thing but that
was my experience let me let me know
what you guys if you guys
have faced similar problems i guess
before um
huge thank you like to you guys honestly
for
helping me for putting me onto the right
track for solving this because i feel
like
if i had not seen this you know you
don't expect something to be like oh
it's taking too long crash
you know that's not usually something it
just takes long that's what i'm used to
um but we can see we can see here that
literally the device state is hung
um and by reducing that time
by reducing like the the complexity i
guess or how much time the computer
takes
that problem went away and i don't have
it anymore on my laptop peter doesn't
have it anymore
um which is which is great and
um so now what i have is like a little
uh actually
let me show you guys this is a bit of a
hazel devlog i should probably show
hazel
right um but basically now what's
happening is
um i've merged everything back into the
master branch
i still have this up i can probably get
rid of this um it's still here
but um inside the settings over here
there's some renderer settings and you
can actually change the environment map
size
and the number of samples um it's
actually like 64 times this but
um it's the number of samples that you
can run um on the compute shader if you
wanted to
uh you know beef it up or whatever so we
have some drop downs there so that
people can kind of configure this based
on their
the power of their graphics card um but
apart from that you know stuff works
pretty well this is vulcan
as i mentioned this is a release um
let's just load something for fun
you know we have this old kind of game
which um is missing its environment map
but you know we can quickly just like
generate um
you know a nice looking environment i
love this little dynamic sky thing
it's pretty cool um and we can just hit
play
and uh there you go that's obviously
hooked up to like c-sharp scripting and
you know we're using box studio for
physics in this example
um it's changing like the material
settings from the c sharp as well
dynamically that's why this goes red
if there's a collision um and everything
is basically
uh working in hazel as expected so
that's kind of um
that's kind of where we're at i guess um
and this is all inside devmaster oh
sorry this is
devmaster i've just got that i've just
got the folder named that it's all
inside the master branch
um inside hazeldev so if you guys do
have access
to that then feel free to check it out
let me know if it's stable on your
computer because my goal obviously is to
get the master branch
as stable as possible if you don't have
access to hazeldev and you want to get
access to everything you saw here
and help support the development of
hazel then you can go to patreon.com
slash the channel and you'll get access
to all the latest
um you know source code that we work on
um
there's like a few active branches
because there's some great people from
the community helping out as well
and we've even got some plans for some
like demo games to show off hazel and
what it's capable of
because we are um we're moving through
this pretty quickly
so anyway thank you as always for your
support i hope you enjoyed this devlog
and i will see you later goodbye
[Music]
you